finalmente estos siete países han
decidido no tomar parte de esta
demostración de esa demostración que
habían anunciado llevar ese brazalete
del Amor libre en un comunicado de
Conjunto dicen que temen que sus
capitanes sean amonestado si es que no
es el mejor escenario comenzar la
andadura no la copa mundo con un capitán
ya amonestado con una tarjeta amarilla
es la principal razón dicen estas siete
federaciones para no tomar parte de esta
protesta hasta hace unas horas solamente
en la última rueda de prensa de la
acción inglesa su capital el delantero
del toten harriquin había defendido esa
voluntad que había para llevar este
brazalete es un país en donde la
homosexualidad es ilegal ese brazalete
en apoyo a la comunidad lgtbi hubo más
había hecho Harvey Kent que tienen esa
voluntad queda saber ahora si habrá la
otra parte de la protesta de la escuela
había hablado Harry kane y es la
protesta de la rodilla arrodillarse
justo antes del comienzo del partido una
demostración que era frecuente hasta
hace muy poco en la Premier League Ese
es la esa de de esa segunda jornada que
se abre aquí en el mundial de Qatar 2022
jornada que se abre aquí en este califa
Stadium que estaba en mis espaldas el
único gran estadio que ya existía en
Qatar antes de esta copa mundo Este es
un estadio que ha sido renovado y que
Data de los años 70 y que era la única
que eran infraestructura futbolística
que había antes del actual torneo Juan y
precisamente hablando de lo plenamente
deportivo la jornada de hoy martes se
abre con el debut de Inglaterra una de
las favoritas o sea para para ganar la
copa del mundo
Así es comienza el camino de Inglaterra
y ya hemos despejado una de las grandes
interrogantes de la jornada Quién va a
jugar en defensa para los ingleses
finalmente el defensa del Manchester
United va hacia el titular va a ser
Douglas con johnsons no habrá defensa de
tres para reemplazar esa bajada de
Walker habrá una línea de cuatro atrás
siguiendo un poco más el estilo general
del seleccionador
ese será el plantel con el que
Inglaterra va a comenzar en este mundial
este mundial en el que vienen como
favoritos llegaron a semifinales en
Rusia 2018 son los actuales subcampeones
de Europa se enfrentan ante una
selección iraní que aquí va a jugar
prácticamente como local veníamos para
el estadio y los que dominaban el camino
los que más estaban animando eran los
iraníes es un país vecino aquí acatar no
tiene las mejores relaciones pero es una
cercanía que no se puede evitar sea nota
un poco un mejor ambiente futbolístico
respecto a lo que vimos Ayer cuando
debutó la Selección anfitriona ahora lo
que queda después de ese partido vamos a
terminar de ver
un partido por el grupo me queda porque
termine la jornada a el partido con
senegal Países Bajos y hoy el para el
día cierra con El encuentro entre
Estados Unidos y gales también por el
grupo B